the first possible mention of Iceland
and historical records could have been
in the now lost work on the ocean by
Greek explorer Pythias in the later 4th
century BCE
thankfully some incomplete description
of his work have survived in later works
of Strabo and Polybius then they
mentioned that Pythias talked about the
land called Thule which was a six-day
sail north of Britain and is near dat
frozen sea paradis weren't the only
mentions of thula and writers like
procopius or osseous pomponius continued
to cite pytheas in their works hard with
very different outcomes some clearly
talked about Norway when they mentioned
through lists some even said Villa was
Ireland or Scotland and some described
foolish location very close to Iceland's
location but there was never any
definitive proof of what thula was
exactly it seems like when ancient
writers were writing about a place that
was very far north they usually just
called a Thule and that's why we are
stuck with writings that when talking
about Thule could be or are mentioning
any of these places and in most writings
we can't even know for sure later in the
6th century CE st. Brendan could have
spotted Iceland and it's volcanic
activity as he wrote that he saw an
island that threw down lumps of fiery
slag powered writings of Saint Brendan
voyages have a very mythical aspect to
them and aren't very reliable first real
mention of Iceland Estela is most likely
by this will an Irish monk and
geographer he states that he has met
clerics that claim to live in thula
which is north of the Faroe Islands and
then continued to explain a little bit
more about the island the statement of
this will that there are Irish monks
living in Iceland during the eighth and
ninth century is supported by the
archaeological finds in a half near
where carbon dating tells us that
Iceland was in fact populated during the
eighth and ninth century and is more
supported by the fact that thora Gilson
writes that small bells corresponding to
those used by Irish monks were found by
the north settlers now whether the monks
left before the Norse arrival in Iceland
or were driven out by the Norse settlers
is unknown the first Norse discovery of
Iceland according to l'anima book the
book of settlements was a no agent named
another daughter who lost his way at sea
and found Iceland which he named
snowland
that's another door there were a couple
more Norse explorers that came to
Iceland like Ghidorah suave arson and
later a raven flock II who named the
island Iceland the story goes that the
Raven floki failed to prepare
accordingly to the Icelandic winter and
so his animals died
as a result and the spring him and his
settlers decided to leave but before he
left he hiked to the top of the nearby
mountain and noticed a large field full
of sheets of ice a frustrated Raven
floki their fur gave it a cold and
unsympathetic name Iceland first
permanent north settler according to the
book of settlements was a Norwegian
chieftain engulfed aridness on the son
of Nora and his blood brother
Lafleur later to be known as here lifer
the most common reason given as to why
they decided to move to Iceland is that
they were warriors that have become
involved in a slaying and moving away to
Iceland seemed like a sensible choice so
in the year 1870 or maybe 1874 but
definitely by the year 1877 ignol fir
managed to set up a permanent residence
in ISIL according to the stories ignore
fur custard is high seed pillars and
vowed to set farm wherever they washed
ashore this happened to be in a bay
which he named that Akiva closely
translating to smoky Bay possibly due to
the steam from hot springs nearby later
in oafers brother and his party was
killed by their celtic slaves putting no
fur managed to avenge them and continue
living in Iceland
now the written records of the book of
settlements and the book of Icelanders
aren't the best reliable sources for
knowing what exactly happened during the
Norse settlement of Iceland many
scholars debate the high seed pillar
story and even in here lifer the blood
brother of ignol fur was real same goes
for the stories of Raven floki and
Garuda suave arson also the fact that
the sources were written around the 11th
and 12th century almost 200 to 400 years
after the supposed settlement of Iceland
doesn't help the reliability now thanks
to ice she dating and carbon dating we
know for sure that there was a human
settlement around Reykjavik in 871
which would support the written records
however there are some archaeologists
that say their excavations investment
Islands
date the settlement of Iceland decades
if not centuries earlier than 871 for
now we don't know for sure exactly when
and how Iceland was settled but we do
know for sure that by the late 9th
century we can find swords and pagan
greys of Norse settlers which is
supported by the book of settlements
indication of the large movements of
Nohr settlers into Iceland during this
time during the settlement period the
book of settlement describes almost
around 3,000 different names of settlers
and 4,000 different areas settled in
Iceland it is believed that most
settlers in Iceland just like ignore fur
came from Western Norway Howard
genetical and some historical records
support a large number of celtic
settlers most likely brought to Iceland
as slaves or wives by the Norse now
asking and explaining why there was the
sudden surge of Norse settlement and
Iceland is like asking why there was a
sudden emergence of Viking activity
across Europe even though there isn't
any one definitive answer to this most
historians accredit theories of social
upheaval changing trade routes and
consolidation of power in Scandinavia
and there is a general agreement that by
the end of the 10th century the influx
of settlers in Iceland died down how
many people exactly lived on the island
at this point is still debated and the
number can be anywhere from 10 to 50,000
people with many people now settled in
Iceland disputes and feud started to
become more common amongst the settlers
to solve these problems people decided
to turn to an age older manic and later
on Norse tradition called a thing the
thing was an assembly made up of free
people from the community led by the
most noble chieftains named gaudy the
thing was supposed to settle disputes
made out punishments agree on boundaries
set up price levels etc naturally with
no centralization on the island multiple
things were created by various
chieftains around Iceland powered by the
year 930 or south or sustained engulfed
s'en and other chieftains in southwest
and Iceland decided to create an all
thing an all-encompassing thing for the
whole island I think he just as any
other thing did not have any army or
police under its power to enforce the
decisions made and therefore the
chieftains wanted to enforce the
decisions of the other thing they had to
do it on an individual level also it is
notable that many of the disputes didn't
even make it to the hell thingy as many
prominent chieftains tried to settle
this peace between their men on their
own or at the very least the men
themselves settled to the speeds between
each other during the 10th and 11th
century we know of their exploration and
settlement of Greenland and also the
founding and temporary settlement of
Finland today's Canada
we mostly know this thanks to the to us
on exec s the saga of Greenlanders and
the saga of Erika red which talks about
thora V north toward our son and his
wife good reader which gave birth their
son while in Finland
Icelanders hailed us as the first
European to be born in America came from
Icelandic descent but there is lots of
dispute about this as the settlers from
Vinland
came from Greenland which in turn came
from Iceland which in turn came from
Norway nonetheless the sagas are in a
very trustworthy source anyways
especially when it comes to particular
details but it is believed that their
overall stories in fact is true back in
Iceland during this time outside of its
Al thingy Iceland wasn't a very unified
country there was no kings no Earl's no
chieftains with direct vassal power as
you would see in mainland Europe also
compared to much of Europe at this point
which was largely Christianized Iceland
was very much happily adhering to their
pagan Norse gods outside of maybe few
small numbers of Christians her when Ola
for three Glasson and eager Christian
convert became the king of Norway he set
out to convert much of the Norse world
including Iceland converting Iceland was
a very hard task and there wasn't much
progress made until 999 when Olaf are
fed up with Iceland's resistance and to
converted chieftains to the Alpha he
proclaiming he would no longer tolerate
defiance also while keeping locked up
several sons of the Icelandic chieftains
after a long debate the Alpha he decided
that the main religion of the island
will be Christianity but pagans were
allowed to worship in secret here the
written records seem to support
archaeological finds which stayed that
pagan burial stopped somewhere around
the early or middle 11th century with
the Catholic Church now established in
Iceland it was quick to gain large power
in the Icelandic society power of the
church could be demonstrated through
many of the churches that grew up all
around the island the churches were also
the centres of learning in Iceland and
priests were oftentimes the only
educated people on the island and most
books were kept in the churches
possession the heightening power of the
church on the island versus the power of
the chieftains created many disputes
over the upcoming years when I started
this channel I released a video about
the history of Reykjavik / Iceland now I
was learning lots of new stuff back then
about YouTube and about how to make
these historical videos and that
unfortunately led me to make several
mistakes in the video many of you
pointed out these mistakes but sadly the
video is still one of the most popular
videos on my channel so to make up for
misinforming a lot of people I made
hopefully a much better and
comprehensive video about the history of
Iceland
you